[Musik]
ergebnis und nahm das spiel zu verlassen
mister x
hier sind ski laufen laufen laufen
ablauf
ich bin tot ich bin tot ich bin so gut
ich betone nicht rausbringen
nein
heute
[Musik]
jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen
zur nächsten folge minecraft waro leute
heute wird es spannend ich habe mich mit
ihm verabredet und zwar nicht für
sonstwas sondern wir treffen uns zum
kämpfen und wollen wir das gemacht haben
ganz einfach wir wollten beide ein
bisschen action ihr habt ja mitbekommen
dass die letzten folgen nicht so ganz
nach meinen vorstellungen waren und aus
dem grund haben wir uns dann ganz
einfach gedacht dass wir uns verabreden
er ist noch nicht auf dem server ich
hoffe mal sehr dass nämlich nicht
reingelegt hat das wäre ein sehr großes
netz muss aber sowas macht auch der der
gute isi nicht
ok ich brauche ich jetzt mal hier so
ganz bewusst so hoch ist immer noch
nicht da wie sie macht keine faxen
das würde ich dir persönlich übernehmen
denn dann würde ich natürlich nicht aber
okay er hat die server betreten
ja da ist ja leute ich bin schon sehr
aufgeregt muss ich sagen und begebe mich
wie gesagt auf den weg zum spot also ich
weiß selbst leute ich habe absolut keine
ahnung wie sie ausgerüstet ist ich habe
mich jetzt einfach mit ihm verabredet
wie gesagt nicht so spannend war
und wenn er jetzt viel besser
ausgerüstet ist nämlich einfach easy weg
klatsch dann ist das so aber dann habe
ich zumindest gekämpft und hatte eine
spannende folge luca ist übrigens heute
nicht dabei das wäre ich wahrscheinlich
auch einige fragen was es damit auf sich
hat ganz einfach
luca ist gerade bei sie okay und jetzt
bin ich an spawn hier haben uns
verabredet bin da und deshalb ist jetzt
zeit nicht dabei ich denk mal wenn ich
gewinne oder verliere rufen einfach mal
kurz an und
werde seine meinung einholen okay sie
er ist auf dem server die aufregung ist
da wir haben uns so besprochen dass wir
kurz am anfang
sobald wir uns sehen einfach 321 in den
chat schreiben und sobald das dann
runtergezählt ist ist der kampf eröffnet
und wir bauen gegenseitig drauf sage ich
mal
glaube ist einfach ganz ähnlich wie ich
auch gefunden dass seine folgen
wahrscheinlich erst ja auch alleine
nicht so spannend sind und deshalb will
einfach gefeiert
ok hier gibt es erstmal ein bisschen
essen für mich
er schreibt alter wenn wir natürlich
jetzt pech haben und irgendwann auf dem
server und nein
jetzt schreibt er ist so weit weg ich
hoffe mal das nicht zu weit weg ist aber
ich habe ja auf jeden fall genug essen
ich könnte auch ein bisschen laufen so
ein kampf gibt es noch etwas was ich
brauche
er ist richtig weit weg
bitte ich sie mich jetzt nicht
ich hoffe mal dass das wirklich alles so
stimmt
[Musik]
okay okay ja gut ich werde es einfach
mal testen denke ich und zu ihm kommen
aber es wird jetzt auch nachts
leute ich habe irgendwie kein allzu
gutes gefühl bei der sache
[Musik]
so
okay leute wie es gerade im chat
geschrieben habe ich gehe es einfach mal
zu der koordinate
ja ich gehe jetzt noch zwei andere
koordinate wichtig ihr merkt schon dass
ich soviel kommentiere so so 606 und 0
661 nur genau darauf 14
dann dürften wir uns demnächst
irgendwann treffen
also ich weiß nicht wie lange es dauert
es anscheinend direkt los gelaufen
ich habe also ich meine ich würde jetzt
nicht so einschätzen dass er mich da
irgendwie verarscht
aber ich meine es das war oder kann man
natürlich nie wissen
aber ich ziehe jetzt einfach mal auf den
lieben sie den ich kennengelernt habe
dass er mich nicht irgendwie reinlegt
okay
[Musik]
kw also ich damit ich denke das wird gar
nicht so lange dauern
hessen habe ich genug und ich habe in
einer folge von easy gesehen der vierten
glaube ich oder so dass er eine diamant
spitze hat das eine diamant spitzhacke
hatte
[Musik]
und die würde ich natürlich gerne haben
dafür wird sich der kampf hat lohn neben
der tatsache dass es ein bisschen
spannend würde aber vor allem halt
einfach damit action gibt so so ewig
lange wird es denke ich mal echt nicht
mehr dauern
ich habe die hälfte vom weg eigentlich
schon geschafft sie brauchen wir hier
unten in der hot war irgendwie noch ein
paar blöcke dass ich mich notfalls
umbauen kann bin schon 380 gysi
dann kann ich ihnen jetzt glaube ich
entgegenkommen wenn wir das jetzt so
machen
[Musik]
ich kann ja selbst nicht so gut nach
koordinaten laufen insbesondere wenn ich
aufgeregt bin aber jetzt gerade läuft
ganz gut
[Musik]
okay er ist moment eine spinne
trotz zweier fehler gemacht also er ist
bei 380 minus 732 okay da muss ich in
die entgegengesetzte richtung laufen
[Musik]
also z richtung null ist natürlich jetzt
noch mal was anderes so als die ganzen
leute die sich zum zum snacken sag ich
was heißt zum seiten verabreden die sich
die kneipen das ist noch mal eine andere
nummer
aber also ich finde natürlich so
schneiden die aufregung kannst du nicht
nicht überbieten also du kannst nichts
spannenderes machen als einfach zu
schleifen weil du bereit sich dann so
lange darauf vor und ob es klappt oder
nicht ist dann einfach alles
entscheidend für die die ganzen folgen
die duh investiert hast und bruder von
ihm zum grabmal sehr interessant gut so
so allmählich dürften wir einander in
die nähe kommen und ich bin aufgeregt
aufgeregter sowie viel pfeil habe ich 34
ist schon mal ganz in ordnung ich weiß
nicht auf erden bogen hat und falls ja
wie viele pfeile natürlich auch spannend
dass wir das jetzt mitten in der nacht
machen pro ist ein killer hase ist es
nicht okay die sind mega selten glaube
ich bin 37 1 - 3 3 3 1
also zehn minuten sind rum
- 36 das heißt er ist direktor vorne
gleich
für 20 24 9
ja ok
vielleicht ist er sogar in diesem dorf
da vorne
okay leute ist mit intense also entweder
hat sie jetzt wirklich reingelegt
oder halt nicht dieses dorf ist er doch
dass das dorf glaube ich ihm und stege
gestorben sind oder zumindest eg vom
piper getötet wurde
und vielleicht ist es auch das dorf wo
ich sterben werde
bzw
also ich bin hier wo bist du sie
davon ist er
ich habe mir schon gedacht dass er sie
besser ausgerüstet sein muss als ich
aber das ist ja doch noch mal was
anderes als er erwartet habe
naja ich werde nicht abhauen ich habe
meine perle aber die werde ich nicht zum
abhauen nutzen da vorne ist
ich gehe mal eben zu ihm
er wird mich besiegen leute also ich
glaube ich nicht so gut in pvp aber ich
mal den countdown und es geht los
ok also ist es glaube ich nicht so gut
im pvp aber ich glaube du könntest auch
schlecht im pvp sein mit dem equipment
kehrt auch ein bogen
es ist dann nicht mal so sehr mein
vorteil wie ich gehofft hatte
in fairen kampf ging mal so sehr
aufgeregt will noch keinen treffer
gelandet
also ich weiß nicht wie viele pfeile er
hat nicht das jetzt hier nach dem krieg
sterben noch schöner php getroffen
schön wäre es wenn er einen krieg
verstrickt
[Musik]
schade ich das gemacht dass ich ihn
vielleicht mit dem klima erwischen kann
okay er hat sogar gold äpfel what the
heck also leute
es läuft nicht nach plan der brennt
schon mal ist aber auch die einzige die
ich gehabt habe deshalb besser zurück
und hoffentlich löst der körper aus ja
okay leute das ist jetzt meine chance
der krater könnte team gegeben haben
nein hat er nicht schade das war es von
mir leid ich kann ich bin response in
war okay und das muss erstmal einer
verstehen
egal leute es war spannend sie hat es
durch gezogen
ich weiß selbst was ihr schreibt okay du
hattest so schlechtes equipment letztes
nicht machen sollen ich hab's einfach
gewollt und dadurch dass jetzt der kripo
ihnen die luft geschossen hat mich
einfach geht s jetzt meine chance ich
hoffe jetzt noch nokia
[Musik]